thank you for coming to my talk I hope
everybody hear me well
so today from Musa typhi I'm a senior
data science platform engineer at Zander
at AT&T we are the advertising arm of
AT&T we do around processing maybe
around between 100 and 200 terabytes of
data per day and we serve around between
40 to 50 billion ad impressions per day
but this is not what I'm here to talk
about I'm here to talk about more like
in a preaching way of you know coming to
you with with examples of of something
that's called clean machine learning
code so I would like to start with a
story time um it's a smelly one I just
had a child recently it's very smelly
kind of story time so this is a capable
junior machine learning engineer with
two years of experience I started
working at let's say a magical insurance
company so he comes in first then he
inherited this insurance prediction
pipeline that predicts optimal premiums
for members management comes to him
until you know oh you know what we need
to do today we need to change the model
from a logistic regression model to a
gradient boosted tree model because of
fly the boosted model works better and
dollars so let's see what he's gonna was
he's gonna find throughout his journey
journeys first onboarding so he clones
the project
so he's like kid yeah this is a great
company I love it but it does that
bullet second thing he finds is that
he's looking for some tests folder in
that project and he finds some notebooks
laying around to test the code manually
this smell is called viscosity of design
then he finds that the notebook unit
tests take around one hour to complete
it's called viscosity of environment he
ventures he's like okay I'm gonna try to
change one name in the last function
tests and he finds that he needs to
change that name in six different places
which is like a rigidity problem next he
gets one related test two on the
gradient calculation problem and he
finds that he broke something on the
test data generating code that's called
fragility then he tries to reuse a small
function from the gradient calculation
he's like I don't know I don't trust
this code enough so he's immobilized and
finally he finds the variable names like
OVH underscore v5 and he's like he's
like you know what did I sign up for
this is not what they was advertised on
the company website so so it's a little
bit of anecdotal story today but but
really I wanted just to you know it's
dear to my heart to talk a little bit
about this clean code how to raise the
awareness of what do we do here as data
scientist and developer spies and
developers and how do we raise this
awareness so that we where we know we
know you know why do we care about this
cleanliness is craftsmanship sort of
spirit it's because honestly the problem
is either it will be what you're
building what data scientist is building
is there too can be costly or dangerous
or even deadly
sometimes we depend on software everyday
for everything your grandma my grandma
like yeah she's buying stuff on some
insurance website she's interacting with
the with software all the time also your
car you know your gas pedal is not
connected to the brakes directly there
is a processor in between their planes
same thing you have a processor in
between the the button that the pie
it's pressing and the actual thing
that's gonna make this this airplane
land you know same thing we've seen
self-driving car hitting pedestrians
there's gender bias on large-scale
translation systems you know you think
that fingerprints on your on your phone
will save the day but then they they're
like ah you know what your screen
protector counts as a fingerprint and
then you have smart system making bad
decisions like you know good night
capital for example and another thing
that people don't realize with this new
field of machine learning is that is
that really almost 40% of data
scientists and m/l engineers you know
have less than five years experience and
and the problems that there's not enough
mentors and teachers and this new cohort
this this energetic young you know let's
let's do it let's deploy let's ship it
are bound to repeat errors of old
cohorts which is not therefore I mean
they're they're trying their best to to
ship something but this talk is really
try to bring back some of the history
lessons that software engineering
brought along throughout the years and
you know advertise them a little better
we have this they're dealing with this
boom of of integration problems and
basically the goal is to have bring the
experience of breathing complex systems
to the machine learning community so
some books that you'd be interested in
if you're starting out and discovering
this Robert Martin so Uncle Bob has a
nice two books that are very nice have
clean code and clean architecture and
what I try to do in this talk is to
really take the concepts that he has
they're related to software engineering
and try to every time I see software
developing software engineering i plug
in machine learning engineering to see
how
changing some words relief like raises
the awareness and there he has two main
goals that we're trying to do here right
so if you need to to sell this yourself
is you you have clean code reduces the
cost of change of your machine learning
pipelines so that's the first one so
cost of change and then it increases the
optimal responsiveness of change to
change of your machine learning pipeline
so in a graphical form you can see this
this is what's gonna happen to your this
is what happens to machine learning
projects across time so on that on the
bottom axis you have time and then you
have two axes on the on the left on the
right side you know I might be just by
preaching to the choir but it's it's
definitely interesting to see you want
at the same time optimal cost of change
you want really low cost of change and
at the same time you want really good
optimal responsiveness but unfortunately
unfortunately as time passes the red
line so the responsiveness to change
decreases and at the same time your
costs increase so this is like a visual
sort of you have to sell it yourself and
then the difference between the cost of
changed and actual cost that you're
seeing like after after one month after
six months after a year of human
training these pipelines you see the
cost slowly increasing increasing it's
called technical debt so I had some
practical principles for you today that
would help a little bit with with with
this with this and it's these five ones
that I want to do you know it helps you
like build vocabulary so that when
you're talking to your teammates you can
actually like talk with similar
vocabulary so you're not just saying oh
this is too complex or this is difficult
this is too costly you want
a little bit more fine-grained
vocabulary so we have loose coupling
high cohesion changes local easy to
remove and mind science components let's
talk about loose coupling loose coupling
coupling is basically when you have to
machine learning components that use
each other and the less ml components
know about each other
the looser they are more true isn't just
like but but the key is that the less
coupled machine learning components are
each other the easily changed and easily
replaced they are so here in the on the
Left work picture we have like you know
a tightly coupled loosely coupled system
where you have this ingestion feature
engineering model training the model
selection are just like stepping on each
other's feet enforcing each other all
over the place you know trouble when you
try to decouple the systems you end up
with a more sort of non cyclic system
where you have loosely coupled
components so that's the first one
second one is high cohesion high
cohesion when you want to talk about
your system and telling you know this is
this design it gives us better high
cohesion is where you you you want your
components that changed for different
reasons or at different times they
should be kept separate so it's varied
the partitioning guideline you have a
component and inside of the component
stuff changes for different reasons
you have low cohesion the third one is
change should be local okay so the you
know most of the cost of machine
learning pipelines is really during the
maintenance phase we need to change this
we need to update that we need to do
this and the more local your changes the
better
and so you really want look it's an
exercise in dealing with boundaries when
you have like clear boundaries between
components then change is local sketch
the fourth one is it is easy to remove I
like I like this one because because we
are at by data I have been up in a
couple talks that that really advertised
budget tooling that we rely on every day
from some great open source and
commercial people and so the the key
here is that those it's like a favorite
of Uncle Bob is that is that they are
all details okay Spencer flow by toward
scikit-learn my sequel hive EMR airflow
cube flow desk pandas did I say pandas
is a detail yes I did say pandas is a
detail you know numpy is not what you
are paid to do the business logic really
the jewels of your business are not to
use the time series component of pandas
or or that the DAGs elements of cube
flow or whatever if they are details
this whole idea came from the fact that
sometimes in in those books that even
the web so the the web itself is a
detail it's not your application it's a
delivery mechanism nothing else the
database is a detail it's rich it's kind
of controversial you know you might be
like ah you know who it is this crazy
man talking about but really but really
like when you think about it your
manager you know your bottom line does
not depend unlike which database you're
gonna be using which javascript
framework you're gonna be using it's
really like that the core business logic
and so these principles here are here to
help you protect your business logic
from the outside components that you
need to use but you want to use them in
a in a respectable crack like a guided
manner so that you don't have to to deal
with you're not at the mercy of
frameworks one nice thing that that
sometimes is mentioned in these books
and talks is that is that framework
managers you know love it when you use
their their their their processes their
processes their libraries and and really
you know it feels like every time you
depend more and more on on a framework
the more you are part of this too
controversial but it's like a harem a
little bit of where they don't depend on
you at all but you depend on them so
much and throughout the years there's a
way to figure out whenever they will
change something in their framework make
sure that it will hurt them more than it
will hurt you it's a very specific thing
so okay so that's that that's the
preaching the fifth one is just that
it's mine science components I don't
think that you can think about about 300
components bunched up in one thing so my
science component is that you want to be
able to test components isolation really
you know in a guideline you don't want
to to have to load up the webserver the
database the browser
you know have a pipeline upstream that
you need to just to be able to test a
specific piece of your code might be
hard you know it's pretty hard to do it
but but that's the that's the the like
the moral center of this of this clean
code architecture channel is that is
that you want to strive towards it
obviously engineering you can't achieve
it a hundred percent but definitely you
wanna strive towards that isolation
being able to test
evasion so now I let me shift gears to
some actionable items we have throughout
the years like software engineering came
up with a bunch of software design
principles that can be applied to you
they are very focused on object oriented
programming which just kind of like that
best we have one of the best way for
like frameworks of thought we have about
software and you know they came up with
this solid software architecture so you
know they're they've been around for a
while I think I I'm doing my job to to
actually raise the awareness about them
again and again so that newcomers you
know people have like one year two years
of experience they never saw them before
could could see them again
they have nice names you have single
responsibility principle open-closed
principle Liskov substitution principle
interface segregation and dependency
inversion let's go through them we have
a blog post about about this how it
applies to machine learning Here I am
might be going a little too fast but but
I invite you to read our blog post to
figure out you know how to start
exploring how can I use some of these
techniques to protect myself and my
software my company from external you
know upgrade of this you know and this
is not supported anymore and separately
so so the first one I wanted to talk is
the single responsibility principle
single responsibility principle is
basically you have a machine learning
component class function should have one
and only one reason to change you want a
single actor that's interested in this
function and that will generate change
for you so here for example we have a
class called
ml model has a fit has a fit for show
has transform features and has published
metrics
now you know it's very easy to add like
things to your class because I might
need this I might need this but when you
think about who's the actor that will
use this and will trigger changes so if
the database change the schema changes
then you transform features we will
change if you if you're you know you
switch from analog cloud watch to to to
some Prometheus they'll publish matrix
is gonna change so you want to really
split this up into into pieces that are
manageable next one I have is the open
closed principle which is kind of my
favorite principle which is you should
be able to extend the behavior of
machine learning component without
modifying what do i do well what do I
mean by here so here we have an example
of at the top you have model manager
right that previously was using simple
feature Iser and it's like happy to use
it you use it we have a new request to
improve the model we need a new filter
Iser we're gonna try to use the super
fit right
unfortunately super franchisor has a
completely different interface which
means that managers can't you the model
manager comes in your method of doing it
is like okay you know the naive way of
doing it it's gonna copy that code put
it there and like you know hard code
everything just to get it work
the the more experienced way is like
okay I'm gonna protect myself against
this change in future versions and by
doing that you try to abstract away the
feature either in an interface and then
suddenly the model manager is able to
swap in these strategies as well as as
nicely as possible and then you know
next week two weeks next sprint somebody
comes different feature Iser pam you can
you can stick a super-duper feature as
it is called open closed principle we
were able to expand the functionality of
model manager without modifying anything
inside the model manager so this code
principle I don't have an example today
but the interface segregation principle
is is a kind of very interesting as well
you have the goal here is to make
fine-grain machine learning component
interfaces that are client specific you
don't want here
we have an image feature either we have
a text feature either a row feature
either and all of them depend on this
data generator this magical class that
does everything which means that if the
even if the image generator only cares
about image feature Iser
only cares about gen images image
fertilizer might have to change if data
generator Gen text changes I mean well
that's like that's like a no-no so what
we try to do is that the we try to
really specialize the interface that
data generator will provide so that
image feature Iser does not know does
not have to know too much it only needs
to know exactly what it needs so that's
called interface segregation principle
the next one is the dependency inversion
principle which is which tells you in a
way to you know depend on machine
learning pipeline abstractions not on
machine learning pipeline concretions
what do I mean by that I mean let's say
we have a model trainer again that is a
good job at like having interface model
builder so that so that we build a model
before we we around the feed function
for example but the problem here is that
there is like instance
problem there is that the model trainer
still needs to know about tensor model
builder implementation so every time we
change something in terms of model
builder implementation model trainer
needs to adapt as well one of the
patterns of inverting just inverting
this this dependency is by using
dependency injection which in a way here
is like one way of doing dependency
injection where we have an assembler
like your main process your main
function that does this assembling and
this wiring so that you can build them
you first create a model trainer and an
assembler creates a model tensor flow
model builder implementation and then
injects it inside the model trainer
animal trainer is able to use the common
interface this one is a little bit more
abstract but definitely the goal is like
am I am I depending on on concrete like
fine-grained low-level policy or am I
you know depending on high-level policy
here we model trainer now only depends
on on high-level policy which is the
interface so so those are the five
source sort of solid principles invite
you to look them up again later
obviously all of this works when you
have like test-driven machine learning
and only thing I wanted to say here is
that it it really increases the trust
that the developers have in your
codebase the more tests you have more
coverage you have and what I wanted to
emphasize it's not it's not reserved to
establish software engineering
components but can be applied to machine
learning components as well so I try to
bring two worlds together
there's the missions act like think some
of you might be familiar with the hidden
high interest rate of machine
in technical debt which is nice paper
from Google from this color which is
deals with really trying to define some
of the machine learning technical debt
that we've seen on the in the while and
how they relate to how they relate to
the these principles so here I cover
four of them so you have entanglement
and blue code is one technical debt
center also this vocabulary is useful
for you to explain to someone that we
have this problem or that problem
second one is hidden feedback loops
thirdly undeclared custom consumers and
the fourth one is pipeline jangles so I
try to figure out the map in between
between our principles that we've seen
listen so the first one is entanglement
what's entanglement is that inherently
inside our ml code you are combining you
know soft like software regular software
if you know loops objects but at the
same time you're combining them with
data and it's an intrinsic part of your
code and so when you have both of these
coming together they're deeply
intertwined and and then as soon as you
have that then you start noticing that
people start adding glue code which is
code that has no real functional utility
except moving data from one part of the
system converting it to another format
and then feeding it to the feeding it to
the machine'll are like prediction
training and so when you see gluco the
entanglement that's a violation of the
single responsibility principle next one
is hidden feedback loops hidden figure
marks is pretty neat except it's such a
static like a weird realization that
you're that you are you're deployed
models in production will change future
training distribution
so your client your customers interact
with your code with your API and then
they they react differently so they
generates a different training
distribution and so what happens is is
that you you need to retrain your model
and by your retraining your model what
you effectively are you know coming from
a traditional software engineering is
that you're allowing users to rewrite if
statements in your model that's
literally what what you know if you let
a flat if let if left unchecked you're
letting your users to reach inside your
your your code which is this machine
learning model reach inside and change
the code inside your machine animal and
it's a it's like an overreach really and
so you you start having data validation
things like that to to catch any drastic
changes but you are noticing that your
machinery model is open for modification
by like an unknown external source which
is kind of you know should be scary for
any machine learning practitioner that
actually makes money or lose money from
or deals with lives but even further is
that you have hidden feature feedback
loops which are these features that you
can't even the text fast enough like
weekly like monthly sums they adapt
really slowly to any changes because
they did with the moving window of of
features that's the folio CP the third
one is this undeclared customers and
declared customers I think it's easier
to understand it's like you have an API
and you know billing is using this API
we're getting it they're figuring out
the room every day how much how much
money did we spend how much money did
you know should we build our customers
they're like amount everything is good
and then you get a report from HR
let's also use this API you didn't even
know that they were using this API and
they're asking you for changes they're
asking you to change the API that you
built for billion so yeah what do you do
what you do in that case they're like oh
we like this machine learning model you
know predicts how much building is gonna
happen so so something in HR actually
now depends on it
this is a sign that you're that you that
the API design has this problem of of of
is not segregated enough that we do not
know we need to be able to shrink the
surface area of API so that so that you
know the consumers that are with us you
know are not they don't sprawl and the
interface figuration principle helps
with that the fourth one fourth one is
pipeline jungles Poland jungles is is is
an unfortunate reality we have pipelines
basically operate at the lowest
abstraction which means that they are
the ones that are moving data from point
A to point B the other ones will trigger
the training there are the ones that
trigger the the batch inference and so
since they they are like they depend on
like low-level concretions people just
you know like to to make that as simple
as possible and so the dependency
inversion principle suffers there where
you are depending your code or pipeline
code now depends on exactly like raw
concretions of some some implementation
which really can can damage your
software and now the data scientist
comes in they're like okay we need to
upgrade this thing here what they do is
that they go potentially and start
torturing this code by adding
experimental code files so experiments
of code pads
our our sign that you have to many a
pipeline jungle you have a jungle of
if-else statements that say you know
we're gonna try this this model on user
IDs that modulo ten equals zero you know
send that much traffic to to this model
and so we have a bunch of experimental
paths obviously projects evolve then we
end up with dead experiments or pets
experiments a pest that nobody cares
about anymore but they're there and it's
a sign that your that your main control
flow has a problem with with too many
responsibilities and how the hell did
they figure out that they are able to
even change this this this code they
should be able to extend it with
external modules external plugins but
they shouldn't be able to go directly in
the in the main control flow and add an
if statement so that the experiments are
because it's fast it's easy people just
just add it so you want to you want to
remedy this with you know shrinking the
shrinking the API that you're providing
shrinking the partitioning the
responsibilities of each part making
sure that you cannot change code and
only extend it and also whenever
something knows too much it's time to
reverse the dependencies so I try to put
them here after like a little bit better
format you know if you see something you
have a Mel problem you have entanglement
or glue code that means that usually
it's related to entanglements as soon as
you change one variable in one place or
one calculation like you're you're doing
you know instead of using seven days in
a week you're only using business days
so five now everything
the change just like affects everything
else can that's a that's a symptom of
violating the single responsibility
principle you have sometimes you have
these god classes that just have you
know thousands of functions or even had
just hundreds of functions you know
there's no need for for bunching a bunch
of functionality inside the third one is
hidden feedback loops we have baggage of
hidden functionality and the realization
that your customers are are able to
directly impact your your your models
undeclared consumers is when you have
unknown clients piggybacking on generic
interfaces that's that's a violation of
the interface segregation principle and
then you have pipeline jangles which
really like we need to depend on more
abstract layers here it's more like a
like a call to action the future sister
of ml engineering is really sort of I
don't want to like doomsday but it's
really definitely that you know what
happens usually in this kind of
industries is that you have a continuous
flow of of machine learning engineers
and then there's like one deadly machine
learning pipeline some you know like God
forbid some some plane crashes inside of
a stadium and then legislators are like
oh wait a minute
this is crazy who are these developers
that did build this thing whole these
data scientists that's you know they
lost basically what they're gonna think
that they lost control of their software
I mean I I I believe that we are you
know reasonable people and really like
honest but if they if legislators
believe that we lost control of our
software that we don't know what we're
doing then their normal reaction is that
is that this is
we'll need to take action by creating
laws well then laws when was last time
you had to deal with the law that some
some of you might be origin like the
health care environment where you have
to abide by a bunch of laws but the
problem with this laws is that they are
made by you know your your your house
representative person your Congressman
your City Council guy which makes it
kind of unbelievable that someone that
has no idea what software is what
software engineering was but with
machine learning is a is able to to set
set up rules of you can only get commits
on Tuesday at 4:00 p.m. you can only
deploy once a quarter you know all your
deployments have to be signed by all by
the mayor you know you cannot deploy
anything without approvals and this is
just I'm trying to raise the awareness
that so that we're aware that this might
have that's pretty much it I have some
references in there I have two plugs
sorry about that
we're we're hiring you have Zander data
science platform engineering push this
link if you're interested also I
organized the New York algorithms coding
practice group sometimes on meetup so
coming if you want to learn about how to
do you know all pad short to spread and
that's pretty much
[Applause]
[Music]
questions anybody really interesting top
thank you for this how has this worked
out in practice at AT&T how has this
worked out in practice at AT&T are you
like educating your data scientists with
all these principles are people lapping
it up in practice like do you see
increase in code quality how do you
measure that
right yeah like how do you measure your
quality the quality of your software you
use well this is all engineering right
so so it's like this this is like goals
we want to go to art and you find that
that like you have two camps I have two
camps of developer you have developers
that that that care about their software
they care about what they do they do it
because they like building software they
like the the abstractions they like and
then you have coders that don't care
they are there for the paycheck and a
good example is open source software
sometimes you find open source software
much better than then then internal
software because people open source they
really you know they do it the
motivation is so much more like morally
elevated I say and so and so that's the
you know I mean this this opinions are
mine so it they're not related to my
employer at all but but definitely the
seniority like it just felt like some of
these concepts we focus on on the
libraries we focus on the frameworks but
we don't focus on on the history of
software engineering you know the 50s
60s software people that are like mature
they came in from from like accountants
and and then they they built all these
base things that we still use today
he knew what deadlines were with
Sprint's were and then and then
since since it became so interesting
software engineering like you double
every five years you double the number
of software engineer same things
happening for ml engineers you have
someone that's been a software engineer
for like you know 20 years and then they
switch to me ml engineering they bring
with them so much implicit knowledge but
you have an ml engineer came out from a
boot camp you know very energetic but
but but they missed they missed the
these principles this this sort of you
know methodologies that really helped
move business forward in a nice
sustainable way so you have this two
camps beckoning them yeah you didn't
talk about a jacquard of books
so thanks um
you had mentioned that undeclared
customers and narrowing like who you're
giving the data to how do you balance
that with duplicating data all over the
place and duplicating like business
logic across like too many teams if it's
very similar right yeah dude in a way in
a way like I think catch back or some
somebody before said that all design is
striving towards did application like so
it's a little I don't know feels like
it's true or not but definitely
deduplicating and so what what you're
asking is like you know how do we how do
we create interfaces that are specific
to customers without creating the
application of of data or or or
functionality or I'm not sure they turn
logic here so you well I mean with this
interface segregation principle you're
not duplicating data a per se like that
you're duplicating how the data
how the API calls are managed from from
like a unified source but but we only
target a specific set of customers I
don't see if I'm not sure we can we can
talk offline not sure how this
application happens yeah yeah yeah I was
just gonna ask if you have written
anything or have some experience about
the utilization of super notebooks in
the pipeline so you know often when I
come across somebody with significant
engineering background they sort of you
know dislike get your notebooks but
Juber networks are a fixture and I'm in
the data science pipeline that's right
yeah they're there they're so easy to
use but if the scientists really love
them and then take those books and then
you want to bring them to production and
it creates like problems when you have
when you have to scan your software I'm
still trying to wrap my head around it
obviously you can see i've i elating a
bunch of piloting a bunch of rules here
because you know like I guess the idea
there the idea there is is to be able to
train your data scientists to
iteratively raise the abstraction level
of their of their software so notebooks
are not bad
there's just need to be coupled with
with some IDE patch are some some other
IDE that will like have a like a like a
dance between the two where you start
your exploration in Jupiter notebooks
and and you promote code to to a more
stable sorts of repo and then I'm even
thinking like you exploring Jupiter
notebooks and you start writing unit
tests you use your Jupiter notebooks to
figure out how to pass those unit tests
then you take code and place it in like
a nice tested place and then you you
refactor your code when you're able to
import stuff in Jupiter note
so that you can continue this
acceleration I think I'm still wrestling
with this problem but yes so definitely
there is a dance between Jupiter
notebooks and more established ideas
yeah alright thank you so much